[موسيقى]
21 طلقة تحية عندما ضربت الدجاج ، كانت
tren de queijo هي لغتي ، لقد تمكنت من
بيع الجملة الجديدة للبيع بالجملة ، يمكنك
التباهي بالعلامة لدينا تجربة 16 لدينا
فريق الرقص لدينا الكثير من
الراقصين في الأيام السابقة
[موسيقى]
توصلت إلى كثافة خفيفة HP ، نحن
في فنون الدفاع عن النفس النينجا ، نشرب
ونرقص الهيب هوب ، كل ذلك في واحد ، أنا
سعيد بردود الفعل ، لذلك
هذا أمر يقرره الأشخاص
الذين يريدون أن يكونوا مثلهم في
الواقع  أنت تعلم أننا لن نكون مثل
النينجا ، فأنت تعلم أن محطة المترو لها
مكان خاص ، لا ، فنحن في الواقع نبني
مجتمعًا في منطقة محطة مترو الاتحاد
، وأعتقد أنه عام فقط من قبل
الناس أيضًا يمارسون اليوغا هناك ولماذا
لا عندما اعتدت  لتشغيل هذا العمل في
الممارسة ، استفد من رقص [موسيقى] في أحد شوارع المدينة
يشبه الرقص شكلًا علاجيًا
يشبه القلب
[الموسيقى]
كما لو كنت غاضبًا وأطلقها فقط
[موسيقى]
إنه أمر جيد خاصة
عندما  're comping وبعد ذلك تنكسر
عندما تشعر بالتوتر الشديد ، فأنت تريد
فقط قتل الأرضية ،
فأنت تعلم أنك تريد التخلص منها
عادةً الديانات والعواطف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]